what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving deep into the new Ark in black
clover the magic war Ark which will pit
Meggie Kula the strongest demon and the
demon kingdom of spade against the
clover and Hart kingdoms the time-skip
is here our heroes including Austin
particular have trained hard and become
stronger and the dark nature of the
Spade kingdoms magic is slowly being
revealed this looks like it's going to
be an amazing arc and the tone so far
seems to be a bit more mature than the
previous arcs as you'll see in this
chapter this arc is already tackling
some harsh subjects and things are
really heating up quickly before we get
into it I want to give a quick thank you
to Epic Games and battle breakers for
generously sponsoring this video
battle breakers is a new anime inspired
hero collector RPG created by a small
and passionate team at Epic Games
assemble the ultimate team of warriors
to take back the planet from invading
space monsters explore over 1,000
fantastical dungeons and clash against
epic bosses using incredible attacks and
special abilities there are hundreds of
heroes to choose from and you can take
your game progress seamlessly across
different platforms including PC and
Mobile which is really useful best of
all battle breakers is free to play on
PC iOS and Android try it out for
yourself just click the link in the
description to download bow breakers for
free the game is a lot of fun the theme
music is so catchy that I've been
singing it all day and it's free to play
so it doesn't cost you anything to join
in on the action just click that link in
the description and enjoy heads up I
will be talking about the latest
developments in the black clover story
so naturally there will be manga
spoilers in this video with that said
please proceed with caution you have
been warned chapter 2 to 9 starts off in
the border area between two countries
inside the grand magic zone a massive
Moving Castle powered by strange magic
is making its way through the stormy
wind swept landscape the Moving Castle
is a mobile fortress designed
specifically for
crossing turbulent magical spaces such
as the grand magic zone and it is clear
that the people who are controlling this
fortress are mages of the Spade Kingdom
it seems to my speculation from the
previous video turned out to be correct
since the Spade mages and probably make
a cool of the demon who appears to be
their leader are using the mana of other
people in order to make themselves
stronger life force is the greatest
source of mana and the Spade kingdom has
learned how to drain this life force
directly from other human beings and
from the lower tier citizens of their
own Kingdom in particular they are using
the commoners and other citizens with
naturally weak mana in order to make
themselves stronger and in order to
power their own magical devices
including this massive mobile fortress
in fact the Spade kingdom mages are
extremely cruel and they have no qualms
about using innocent civilians and even
children in order to power this fortress
even if that means exhausting all of the
life force that these people possess
leading the people to collapse from
exhaustion and possibly even die this
chapter definitely gave me some Magness
thought vibes from moggy season to the
water spirit
Ondine is able to track the mobile
fortress using her water-based magic and
Beaver girl reveals that over the course
of the past six months the Spade kingdom
has expanded rapidly they have taken
over almost all of the diamond Kingdom
and large chunks of the neutral
territory as well and they are now
beginning to advance towards the heart
and clover kingdoms beaver girl confirms
that the spade kingdom mages are using
low tier citizens of their own society
as objects and draining their life force
in order to push through the grand magic
zone as a commoner from the forsaken
realm and as someone who cares deeply
about social fairness and equality auste
is outraged by this and he flies off as
soon as he learns the truth Gaea notes
that the Hart Kingdom mages have always
considered their strong affinity to the
mana of nature to be their greatest
asset
but in these past few months they have
been able to witness something
unprecedented a person with no mana
whatsoever auste has apparently been
able to become extremely powerful
through training and hard work
bieber girl is also impressed by
austin's abilities his demon powers are
definitely unique and that is why he is
classified as dark tear but he is also a
lot more than that he is incredibly
brave hardworking and he refuses to give
up no matter what all of these things
combined allow us to keep getting so
much stronger so quickly so hasta is
apparently on his way to the mobile
fortress of the spade kingdom but he
hasn't arrived yet
meanwhile the Spade mages inside the
fortress are replacing one batch of
commoners who have collapsed from
exhaustion with another batch of
presumably fresh commoners who are about
to be drained of their mana as well a
young commoner woman begs the mages not
to take a little girl presumably her
sister or daughter but the Spade mage
who appears to be in charge merely
laughs he grabs the young woman's face
and he tells her that she must learn
some respect since she is a low tier
commoner and he is an officer of the
army he says that people like them who
don't have high levels of mana don't
possess any proper attack magic and this
makes them useless as far as the army is
concerned and the only thing that they
are good for is powering the armies
transportation devices with their life
force the army officer then proceeds to
assault the young woman but thankfully
in that very moment asta bursts through
the walls of the mobile fortress with
his sword and it looks like he has found
a way to fly with his sword without
using the black ass to form he has a bit
of a rough landing
apparently he still hasn't perfected
this flying ability he is using but his
abrupt entrance is thankfully enough to
take the officers attention away from
that young woman I have to say really
quickly that the actions of this officer
that we have just seen really drive home
the idea that the spade mages have no
empathy or compassion whatsoever for the
low tier citizens of their own Kingdom
they treat them as if they were less
than human they treat them as nothing
but objects living and breathing magical
batteries I thought that commoners were
treated poorly in the clover Kingdom and
they definitely are but this is even
worse these Spade mages really are the
lowest of the low they have no sense of
humanity and no sense of kindness for
their fellow man if Magee Kulas special
ability really is
draining the magic of others and if he
really is the leader of the spade
kingdom then it is likely that he has
deliberately fostered this type of
behavior among the Spade kingdoms mages
after all the more culturally and
socially acceptable it becomes for
stronger mages to use weaker citizens as
nothing more than walking talking power
sources the easier it becomes for Maggie
Kola to take advantage of these people
in order to increase his own power
Aastha then rises to his feet and he is
actually able to summon his sword back
into his hand by calling out to it not
only is this pretty cool but it shows
that hasta has drastically improved his
control of anti-magic in these last few
months he is also wearing the black
bull's robes but no undershirt and he
looks even more buff than he used to
look before the time-skip clearly the
intense training that he has undergone
over the past six months the training
that impressed both beaver girl
and Gaia has also had a significant
impact on his physical stature the army
officer and the other soldiers are
surprised that a knight of the clover
kingdom would appear here so suddenly
and on his own but they are convinced
that they will have no trouble in
killing him
however hasta basically says I'm about
to end this man's whole military career
and he uses his massive sword to rip
through the army officers magic this
move instantly whips the officers asked
and it stuns the other soldiers and from
this scene it is clear that asta has
gained more control even of his
strongest attacks hasta says confidently
that no matter how many of these Spade
soldiers there are he will take them all
out in an instant and he calls out to
all of them to basically come at him bro
I mean hasta might not even have to use
his sword at this point he could just
hypnotize the soldiers with his chiseled
abs at the very end of the chapter we
see the orphanage back at hog a village
sister Lily
opens the door and when she steps
outside she seized a collapsed body of a
man this man whom sister Lily does not
recognize calls out to you know and
according to some translations
he says master you know although there
are always a number of different
translations out there and some are more
accurate than the others so be aware of
that
this could be a major development in
terms of unraveling you know
true origins and perhaps asked us true
origins as well we know you know and
hasta were dropped off at the orphanage
as children but we don't know by whom or
why nevertheless we now have someone
showing up 15 years later and looking
for you know and if the master you know
translation can be trusted this would
indicate that you know is not a commoner
at all in fact this man calling you know
master you know suggests that he might
actually be from a noble or even royal
family obviously this final scene raises
a lot more questions than it actually
answers if you know an hasta were not
dropped off at the orphanage because
their parents were too poor to take care
of them if there was some other reason
then this will change everything we
thought we knew about the black clover
story if you know really is a member of
a noble or even royal family then why
was he given up to an orphanage and why
all the way in the forsaken realm was
his life in danger for some reason and
he was left all the way out there for
his own protection so that he wouldn't
be found if so why was he in danger and
who was looking for him
did his family maybe do something they
shouldn't have done or do they know
valuable secrets or was you know set to
inherit a lot of money or power and
there were powerful people out there who
didn't want this to happen and then
there's also the question of hasta and
why baby
hasta was dropped off at the orphanage
along with baby you know at the same
time what's the real connection between
the two of them the man was found by
sister Lily didn't mention hasta but
does that mean that this man doesn't
know about hasta or does he consider you
know to be more important because he is
from perhaps a noble family and hasta
isn't it's crazy how this one page of
the manga can raise so many questions so
quickly in some ways this part left me
even more excited than Asta's power-up
and now I am extremely intrigued to find
out more about this man and why he is
looking for you know also if you know
and hasta do have a secret past hidden
origins
what is this past there are just so many
questions but I guess that's the beauty
of a good manga they just keep you
wanting
or every single week let me know what
you guys think what are your thoughts on
the Spade Kingdom soldiers and what are
your thoughts on Austin's new powerup
finally what do you think of the
collapsed man at the end who is asking
for you know definitely share your
theories about the secret origins of you
know and hasta down in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
us to keep the black clover content
going please leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest black clover news and
updates I want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons who
support us and make videos like this one
possible special thanks to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh baby Rey nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings ell dress fitted ala
beat Anatole Cassatt Sookie DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget are the
one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including Ingrid
ah a lowland Adam Maddy Mac makoto-kun
and the world and you know he's serious
because he didn't say so Waldo if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value to your life please
consider becoming a patron even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us bass cowboys
[Music]